have your periods improved in any way on  the lion diet were they bad before so I  always had like about eight day periods  now it's hard to say because I was also  taking birth control for honestly from  like 14 to 23 when I stopped taking my  medications so I don't even know what a  regular period would look like I know  that before I went on birth control I  had pretty bad cramping I have  absolutely no cramping now I would  attribute that to diet but it's also  hard to say because I didn't actually  stop taking birth control until I  started going on Paleo and things and  even paleo really improved my cycle but  my cycle is super normal and about six  days long and absolutely no cramping